good morning believe nation today's
message is be passionate over to you
Mark Cuban the passion I've always had
for business and being an entrepreneur
the trend that transfers into the Mavs
I've always been passionate some people
thought you know it's a it's more OCD
than anything else which i think is a
great trait for an entrepreneur when I
you know I mentioned the stamp business
I would stay up til 3:00 4:00 in the
morning even though I had to get up and
go to school and read Lin stamp news and
Scots stamp journals and have them all
memorized and and use that to give
myself an edge even when I was in
college I'd be in live in the library
reading business books and just looking
for business biographies and just
reading all I could about business when
I had Micro solutions and you know I
started with no money
you know I pull all-nighters in in front
of borrowed computers teaching myself
software and how to program if you want
to have success and you need to work for
it and the only way you're gonna put in
the hours is if you're passionate about
what you're doing
Mark Cuban put in the time to learn
about stamps that gave him his edge and
he became successful and in every other
business that he became involved in he
out worked his competition because he
was passionate about it when I make
these videos I do two or three a day
because I'm passionate about it when I'm
responding to comments from you guys
till three four or five in the morning
is because I'm passionate about it
that's my edge when other people are
complaining that they don't have the
time to make one video per week I stand
out making 2 to 3 per day because I'm
passionate about it that's my edge now
go find yours
so my question today for you today is
what's your edge how did your passion
lead you to find your edge that lets you
beat the competition leave it in the
comments below
thank you so much for watching continue
to believe have an amazing day and I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of vinspresso